this deposition shows you why it Remains
the case today that Donald Trump is the
most likely 2024 Republican nominee take
it away and you say it again this has
become very famous I just start kissing
them it's like a magnet just kiss I
don't even wait
and when you're a star they let you do
it you can do anything grab them by the
you could do anything that's what you
said correct well historically that's
true with stars if you look over the
last million years I guess that's been
largely true not always but largely true
unfortunately or fortunately and you
consider yourself to be a star
I think you can say that yeah
I don't know what I was expecting when I
started playing this clip but it
exceeded even my expectations